today's negotiations, as always, took place
in a constructive and business-like atmosphere, and
naturally there was talk of ending the
so-called Black Sea
initiative for the export of grain from Ukrainian
ports on July 18. Mr. President paid
considerable attention to this, as he has
said more than once, we were simply forced to make this
decision, I have in Russia been forced  since
Western countries have blocked and continue to
block the implementation of
the deal in terms of ensuring access for
Russian agricultural producers to
world markets, that is, they refuse to
withdraw the export of our
grain and fertilizers from the substation, resume supplies of
agricultural equipment and spare parts to Russia, resolve
problems with logistics and freight of ships,
banking services and
food insurance  supplies, I
would like to reaffirm our
principled position, we will be ready to
consider the possibility of reviving the
grain deal. I
told Mr. President about this again today
and we will do this immediately as soon
as all the
agreements recorded in it on
lifting restrictions on the export of Russian
agricultural industry are fully implemented
We have always agreed that these
corridors are intended for the export of
food and should not be used
for military purposes;
unfortunately, they are used by the
other side, we see this as well as
attempts are being made on the
Turkish Stream and the Blue Stream, through
which gas is supplied to the Turkish
Republic from Russia, ours  ships
protect these flows, these pipeline
systems And they are constantly attacked,
including with the help of drones that
are sent to these attacks from the ports of the
Ukrainian ports of the Black Sea. Well,
agree on everything that nothing
like this will happen, the
promises given to Russia will be fulfilled,
we will all return to us  there are no
problems here, just no problems to be
sorry
Ukraine
Russhaya is
close to completing agreements with
six African states where
they intend to supply food
for free and even supply
logistics to deliver this cargo for free
negotiations are almost close to
completion in the next couple of
weeks there, delivery will begin
[music]
[applause]